mainstream TV viewers often overlook
horror but American Horror Story managed
to seduce an audience all its own here's
a look behind the scenes into what it
took to bring the beloved anthology
series to the small screen before
American Horror Story debuted in 2011
co-creator Ryan Murphy was best known as
one of the minds behind Glee a show so
happy and positive that it was literally
about a bunch of high school kids
gaining self-esteem by singing and
dancing too familiar pop songs Murphy
then went directly from his high school
musical to a house full of ghosts
violence and the rubber man what
happened
who hurt you Ryan in an interview with
Elle Murphy admitted I was like I can't
write any more nice speeches for these
Glee kids about love and tolerance and
togetherness to that end he wrote a show
about horror and depravity instead
American Horror Story also allowed
Murphy to write ugly wrong it wanted
Sarah Paulson to play Emma Pillsbury the
high school guidance counselor
eventually portrayed by Jayma Mays
Paulson was unable because she was
starring in a Broadway play at the time
Murphy finally found a place for Paulsen
as medium Billie Dean Howard the first
of many memorable AHS roles she would
step into so much pain here
so much longing and regret while
occasionally Kumbi and darkly funny most
every season of American Horror Story
gets pretty bleak pretty quickly I mean
just because you got 30 bodies buried in
your crawlspace don't mean you can't
have a really terrific rec room and be a
respectable businessman playing
murderers and their victims can really
get under the skin of the actors so a
few have tried to relieve the tension
when possible
Zachary Quinto took on a major role in
asylum as Oliver thredson another role
he accepted onset music therapist
playing his banjo on set to lighten the
mood
Lily Reba plays guitar in real life and
should play to provide musical breaks on
tough days - yeah musical break it was a
case it was kid Zak is better at the
banjos and I am at the guitar for sure
Jessica Lange the grande dame of
American Horror Story convinced Ryan
Murphy to put one of those melodic
palate cleansers into the show itself
after a flashback for a veal that our
Asylum character had once been a singer
in a band lang suggested a full-on
fantasy musical sequence in the middle
of a psychiatric institution set to the
classic 60s novelty song the name game
if only because as she told vulture
everything we do is so grim let's be
real lots of people are afraid of clowns
American Horror Story aptly exploited
those fears in its freakshow season
featuring John Carroll Lynch as a
monstrous twisty the clown there wasn't
so much a children's party entertainer
as he is a guy who kills people with
scissors and the lots kids at an old
school bus please release the world
perhaps unsurprisingly at this subplot
upset some real-life clowns in 2014
clowns of America president Glenn Cole
burger said in response to freak show
Hollywood makes money sensationalizing
the norm they can take any situation no
matter how good or pure and turn it into
a nightmare we do not support in any way
shape or form any medium that
sensationalizes or adds to core phobia
the protests flared up again in 2017
when American Horror Story cult
once again featured evil clowns world
clown Association president Pam
moody told the Detroit Free Press the
role of a clown persona regardless of
their style of clowning is meant to
bring joy and laughter to bring humor to
a hurting world before it was cancelled
in 2017 scream queens whine Murphy's
other other show was the place where the
blood and gore of American Horror Story
met the comedy of Glee for instance its
first season as the burning question how
might a cast made up of self-absorbed
sorority girls and dumb frat guys deal
with a costumed serial killer roaming
their college campus it was also laced
with references to classic slasher
movies tongue-in-cheek horror movie
tropes and they even starred Halloweens
Jamie Lee Curtis in a major role while
the male sound pretty standard for the
guy who conjured up the dead Breakfast
Club scream queens nearly had even more
in common with American Horror Story
just how much you ask well it was almost
a spin-off of coven the AHS season set
at a school for young witches in New
Orleans surprise [ __ ] I bet you thought
you'd seen the last of me however Murphy
changed his mind after a lunch with Fox
executives explaining we were talking
about things that we loved that were not
on the air things that we loved growing
up a movies that we loved watching once
the subject of slasher movies came up
scream queens own unique identity began
to take shape and while its ride was a
short one it sure was a blast while it
lasted
in the months before the sixth season of
American Horror Story premiered in 2016
FX released more than 20 teasers each
suggesting a totally different theme at
a Television Critics Association event
effects CEO John Landgraf explained that
only one of them accurately represented
the season for the rest were mr. X
though wildly different the trailers did
share a few things in common all of them
were creepy weird and pretty damn
unsettling perhaps none more so than the
one that showed a woman using some hedge
clippers to snip a wind chimes made from
human teeth turns out that was a real
trailer as that imagery figures into
American Horror Story roanoke in a way
though all of the fake trailers were
real that season of the show explored
the notions of real and fake as the plot
centered in part on a couple who lived
in a haunted house near the Lost Colony
of Roanoke and the TV shows recreations
of the events they endured at the hands
of the ghostly Roanoke colonists in
American Horror Story hotel Evan Peters
portrayed mr. March who turns out to be
arguably the most super evil character
in the show's long list of super evil
characters I look around and I see the
definition of American success why well
because he trapped tortured and killed
people in the hotel Cortez door it's
quite upsetting then that according to
Ryan Murphy in Entertainment Weekly mr.
March is based on a real person that's
individualist HH Holmes who joined the
Chicago World's Fair in 1893 opened and
ran a hotel of Horrors visitors to the
great exposition who tragically chose to
stay at Holmes as hotel would find their
rooms soundproof and windowless all the
better for Holmes to take them out via
gassing or other means secret
passageways allowed him to remove bodies
for the basement without detection where
he'd destroy the evidence and a furnace
he was caught in 1894 and executed two
years later
[Music]